[Music]
i've never forgotten i think it was
about
six years of age when mum brought this
huge tray of eggy bread to the table and
it was like wow
mum we've died and gone to heaven start
off with a slightly stale bread
four or five day old loaf left over if
it's a fresh bread then it absorbs too
much of the egg so therefore it gets
soggy you never get it fried and crisp
and if you're not gonna use it for
breadcrumbs eggy bread is a must
in france they call it pan perdue the
lost loaf
now eggy bread is great on its own but
serving it with stewed apples is
delicious so the secret here
keeping the skins on it's a lot of
flavor in the skin and also it stops the
apple from breaking down too quickly
they get these nice chunks as opposed to
a sort of apple puree
[Music]
now get your pan nice and hot and
sprinkle a couple of tablespoons of
sugar
take the sugar down to a light caramel
it's quite incredible how cheap it is to
make this and yet it was so filling
if you haven't got apples this recipe
will work pretty much with any fruit
you've got in
don't be scared to mix a pear and an
apple a banana and a pineapple just chew
it
lightly toss in the caramel
get a little knob of butter
that makes a nice toffee apple flavor
really simple
now
you can see what's happening the apples
are caramelizing but they're staying
intact because the skins on the apple
and the caramel has turned into this
nice rich butterscotch sauce
once you've glazed all the apples a
couple of tablespoons of water in there
bring that ball and let that cook out
now the eggs
three whole eggs
whisk up the eggs
add about four tablespoons of milk
you want the egg
thick and rich
and then lightly sprinkle in a couple of
tablespoons of sugar
that sweetens up
the mixture and when you start frying
the bread
it caramelizes it beautifully
a teaspoon of powdered cinnamon that
gives the bread that really nice spicy
deliciousness
apples are glazing beautifully
and put them on a low heat and get a pan
on now for the bread
a teaspoon of oil that stops the butter
from burning butter in
as that starts frothing get your bread
in it's going to be pretty quick now now
you don't need the bread
soaking
drain
and in the pan
once your egg bread has browned flip it
over
90 seconds each side
that butter gives that nice golden brown
color of that egg
[Music]
beautiful
absolutely beautiful
it's quite remarkable isn't it a couple
of eggs splash of milk leftover apples
and all of a sudden you've got this
stunning breakfast
[Music]
now
my apples they've all glazed beautifully
get a nice spoon of that amazing juice
and drizzle that over hmm
wow
if my mum saw me doing this she'd kill
me you're getting all posh again no no
i'm using a touch of iced sugar to make
it look stunning
and that for me takes me back to when i
was six years of age
and i thought
i just won the lottery
that
is incredible
thank you brett
[Music]
you won't get more breakfast for your
buck my mum's incredibly delicious
cinnamon eggy bread with quick stewed
apples
[Music]
a delicious saffron flatbread with
mussels it doesn't get any healthier
than that first job the super easy
saffron flatbread
put the saffron
into the bowl
and a couple of teaspoons of hot
water that starts to infuse
the saffron
and so you can maximize on the colour
across your flatbeds
to make the dough simply add plain flour
a pinch of salt and pepper to a bowl and
then pour in a dash of olive oil that
makes the dough nice and silky and rich
your saffron water you'll see how
concentrated it is now
and you'll need cold water
then simply need to bring the dough
together mop up
all your flour
you can see now
the saffron's activated it's got that
really nice color
beautiful
use your wrist
and just knead it nicely we'll do now is
smoothing out
the gluten strands
push
and tuck in
push and tuck in and each every time you
do this getting softer you just sort of
form
like this perfect
beautiful
dough
it smells delicious that saffron is very
powerful
now sit that in your bowl cover it with
clint film let it rest for 10 to 15
minutes
this relaxes the dough making it easier
to roll and gives it time to infuse with
the saffron i'm gonna cut that into
three and then roll them nice and thinly
now
lightly flour the surface
and then
just
bring that
to like a perfect ball
on the board
once you've got that nice ball your
rolling pin
and just roll it out
now
it doesn't get any simpler than that
and just lightly
flour that on top
a little salt
cooking the flatbread is easy just pop
in a hot dry pan and they're ready in
minutes as it hits the pan it starts the
blister
she's ready for turning
beautiful get the color on there
now you want it nice and crisp almost
blistering on both sides because it's
nice and thin
it's cooked once browned on both sides
just cool on a rack flatbread's done now
onto the mussels now the secret
behind cooking
great muscles
is in the speed you cook
the key is to chop and prep your
ingredients before you start cooking
first thing pancetta i want it quite
chunky if you can't get pancetta i
always like to use a sort of streaky
bacon
because i want to sort of render all
that flavor
at the streaky bacon
now tomatoes garlic and chili
cherry tomatoes they're just going in
whole the garlic
just crush the garlic
so all that flavor comes out
chilli
i want some heat in here
that's everything prepped now to get it
cooked little touch
of olive oil
pancetta in
pancetta takes moments once it's brown
and crisp put your garlic chili and
whole cherry tomatoes into the pan
mussels go in
okay and i'm using dry sherry i think it
works better in this recipe than white
wine which is classically used at this
stage
then oregano finely chopped stalks and
all i'll go on
and then just give that
a little mix
and we'll see those muscles
start to open lid goes on
you've got to lock in that flavor
got to lock in
that heat the muscles will take four to
five minutes to steam in the meantime
cut your flatbreads into strips
crispy
and crunchy
now the mussels
wow that is incredible
my goodness me
[Music]
now that is one lunch i definitely
don't want to miss
healthy and delicious
doesn't get any better than that
incredible
steamed mussels with saffron flatbreads
made in minutes and packed with protein
and vitamins this is one fast food meal
that really is healthy
[Music]
line of venison one of my favorite meats
slightly gamey absolutely delicious it's
packed with protein low in cholesterol
and so it's like the rolls-royce cut is
phenomenal
i'll cut it into four marinade olive oil
salt
pepper
thyme is a very sort of dainty soft
sweet herb and it goes brilliantly with
the rich gaminess of the venison juniper
berries
the flavor is almost like a sort of rich
bittersweet slightly peppery flavor
garlic get the back of your knife on it
get the loin place it on top
olive oil
season
leave that to marinade and that's ready
for the pan
cooking the venison you've got to be a
lot more delicate than you were if
you're cooking a fillet of beef because
it's very lean hardly any fat on there
hot pan
olive oil
keep on rolling it around it should
become nice and springy and slightly
bouncy and that indicates that it's
slightly pink
but a little bit firm in the center
butter
baste
the venison
and then just take it out of the pan and
just spoon it over there leave that to
sit now for the sauce we're gonna do a
really nice sweet and sour pepper red
and yellow pepper just stand the pepper
up on its base and just cut around like
we're segmenting an orange and look
you've got the seeds there fit for the
bin
olive oil in peppers in the pan
a little bit of salt and by having the
skin on the peppers it doesn't allow the
peppers become too soft and overcooked
it keeps them really nice and robust
thyme
this is where it gets really exciting
white wine vinegar
smells amazing but it starts to glaze
the peppers a couple of tablespoons of
water in there
you've got this really nice
sweet and sour peppery vinaigrette at
the bottom peppers out
carved
nice thick slices
and look the juices coming out of the
peppers
a little bit of
salt just
glaze the venison with some extra virgin
olive oil and then look venison with
sweet and sour peppers done